in this program you will learn about  analytical methods for processing  visualization and analysis of complex  biomedical data you will understand the  terminology for machine learning in  artificial intelligence and biomedical  discovery and see project examples where  machine learning was used effectively to  achieve meaningful results  you will also hear about commonly used  machine learning algorithms for  analyzing all mixed data understand the  differences between machine learning  models and problems they can be applied  to  see the different applications of  machine learning for omics studies and  project design objectives and gain  experience with popular python and r  packages for data visualization analysis  and machine learning  most importantly you will learn to use  your understanding to work on industrial  and research problems of the 21st  century  precision medicine population health  biotechnology  agriculture and space onyx